trente mille nouveaux décès liés aux
kovy 19 en une seule semaine
le chiffre fait froid dans le dos et il
est certainement inférieur à la réalité
ces images de crématorium à ciel ouvert
sont devenues quotidiennes
le manque de moyens à tous les étages
est pointé du doigt par les habitants à
commencer par le déficit de médicaments
c'est mon père il a été infecté par le
cos vide au début nous l'avons soigner à
la maison mais certains médicaments dont
le gouvernement avait dit qu'il avait
besoin n'était pas disponible
alors il a attrapé une pneumonie avancé
c'est seulement là que nous nous sommes
précipités pour l'admettre dans un
hôpital à mesure que l'épidémie a flambé
ces dernières semaines bon nombre
d'indiens se montre critique envers le
gouvernement du premier ministre
narendra modi et comme si le virus
n'était pas suffisant une autre
redoutable maladie vient nourrir le
cauchemar indien
l'amuq hormis cause aussi appelé
champignon noir touche de nombreux
patients guéris du coc vide 19
elles attaquent notamment les zones
centrales du visage la sphère orl et les
poumons
d'après les premières données
disponibles son taux de létalité
dépasserait les 50%
l'utilisation de stéroïdes pour traiter
certains cas de kobe 19 ferait grimper
les niveaux de sucre est associée au
manque d'activité physique expose les
personnes diabétiques un risque plus
élevé d'attraper la nuque hormis cause
si la communauté internationale s'est
mobilisée pour apporter de l'aide
matérielle à l'inde au cours du mois
écoulé cela semble encore resté
insuffisant pour un pays qui compte un
milliard 400 millions d'habitants
tous en quête de nouvelles plus heureuse